Hayden Panettiere made her way down the
early sections of the Disney actress to
pop star path recording songs for
several Disney movies including Ice
Princess and Cinderella 3 A Twist in
Time she even started working on her own
album releasing a single entitled
wake-up call in 2008 but she wasn't
happy with the music that her record
label was pushing her to sing and has
since revealed her dissatisfaction with
this release she said in an interview
with falcher at that point I was a
puppet basically it wasn't me however
these unpleasant experiences in the
music industry have proved useful to her
as an actress while playing Juliet on
Nashville Panettiere took her
experiences into account as her
character was encouraged to record music
she was not passionate about when I read
this script and it became that for
Juliet I was like I understand I know
what that is